for
right a little after 10:15 and I
apologize for uh for being late but we
had some other business we uh we needed
to have some discussions on I'm going to
call the uh house Judiciary Committee to
order and I as the first order of
business would you please stand and join
me in the Pledge of
Allegiance Pledge of Allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation
indivisible andice for
all all right
um we have a number of bills to uh exec
uh today and there are some of those
that are on the schedule for exing um I
believe we are not we're just not ready
to exec because there are either
amendments or or other issues that have
to be uh discussed
um since I know that uh House Bill 1283
is a bill that has generated you know
probably the probably more attention
than than uh any any others I guess I
would like to introduce that uh first um
as something uh to talk about and I and
um guess I would recognize uh
representative Smith if I could on that
please
thank you um Mr chair and I look out and
although I never wear badges or symbols
of I see a lot and I know many people
are here for uh for this particular bill
but I have a problem um that i' I'd like
to raise
um members of the committee have
identified several amendments that they
would like to have
considered um on this bill but none of
the
Amendments um have
been able to be presented to us yet so
I'm concerned about our moving
to towards voting on a bill where we
don't have all the details yet um and I
know how disappointing that would be for
people who have traveled here and
we we honor their commitment to the
issue but think that I would suggest
that we put off
discussion and eventual voting on this
bill for um till next week when we when
we have already posted that we would
deal with the bills we couldn't deal
with today I believe that's next
Wednesday afternoon on the 21st is that
correct that that is correct that is
correct thank you um so I guess what I
would what I would say is this just and
I want to hear from what other people
have to say about this but my
inclination is that um repr
representative Smith is correct and that
would be my inclination of what to do
also and I just just to to
put um uh a little more detail on that
for among the amendments to people who
were here at the hearing may recall that
there was some testimony we heard from a
um I believe two representatives of
Pharmacists as to whether or not they
should be included in the bill um and
um that seemed to make sense as I as I
as I tried to go through it the bill
line by line
um I'm I'm I'm not completely convinced
whether we need to put them in there or
not um in terms of uh of uh what would
make the most sense but that's one one
possibility that that we need I think we
need to think about um more carefully
and the other uh the other just a couple
of other examples there has been
some uh talk about whether or not um
right now the bill uh uh
contains
um among the people that can
be
uh uh Prov uh healthc care provider are
included
um uh an advanced practice registered
nurse license pursuant to RSA
326b and a physician's assistant uh
license pursuant to
328 uh D um and there's been some uh
discussion about
um whether it's appropriate to include
those uh those individuals or should it
just be limited to um should uh uh
physicians assistant be removed or
should physician's assistant and
advanced practice registered nurse be
removed so that it would be limited only
to a physician or an osteopath the other
uh thing that I discovered is that there
is
some I think there may need to be
some cleanup for lack of a better term
of language in the bill for example one
of the terms that's defined in the bill
is
um uh healthc care
provider um and and
uh I'm sorry one of the one of the terms
that's defined is in the bill is
prescribing healthc care
provider but later in the bill
that the term attending physician is
used or attending provider is used and I
think
that I don't think that there my
impression is that that was not intended
to be a substantive change
but as somebody who has worked with
language in my past life um I understand
that sometimes there using different
words when you mean the same thing can
be a problem so uh that might be
something that needs to be looked at
also so for those um for those reasons
my
inclination um would be that we are not
ready to vote on uh 1283 today um that's
my inclination other people have any uh
any other view representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair um I believe there
are a number of members that may want an
amendment or something to clean up what
you said was deeply flawed language but
I think there are a number of members
that are ready to vote on a deeply
flawed bill today so I'm happy to wait
if the committee decides that but I'm
ready to vote today thank you all right
yes representative Perez I know you
mentioned a couple of the thing cleanup
things but I have gone through the bill
as a healthare provider not a lawyer as
a health care
provider line by line there's a lot more
residents requirement lots more what the
bill does for normalizing normalizing
suicide for teens there's a lot of words
what is reasonable me medical judgment
there's a lot of cleanup that needs to
be done whether you are for this or
you're against it the amendment itself
in my opinion as a medical
person for 42 years plus the bill itself
is flawed I I don't think there is
anything you can do in a week to clean
up this bill and make it appropriate for
what we're looking at and I'm ready to
vote on it as well so let me I just I
guess what I just wanted to ask
representative pres make sure I'm
understanding is I mean is there
anything are there you said you've
you've you've gone through the bill
you've seen a number of things that need
to be cleaned up are are are are those
things that you would propose amendments
or or is your position that no matter
what the Amendments would be you're
still opposed to the
bill I don't want to put in amendments
on these things I have no idea how to
clean this up I have no idea how to take
line 20 reasonable medical judgment and
make that cleaned up I have no idea to
you know coercion how to clean that up
uh provider must have health records all
the records since the person was
diagnosed there's a lot I I don't know
how to clean up this bill okay I think
the bill needs to um I I'm I'm concerned
about what we want to do with this bill
I know a few years
ago people knew it was open up to other
things I don't know if this is similar
to that bill but I mean does the bill
need to be r re retained I I don't know
if you can clean it up and how I feel
about it I have two sides I have the
first generation Italian Catholic and I
have the legislature I have not heard
from one of my
constituents that they want this bill so
that's the legislator side of yes
representative Kenny um well just on
that I've heard from a lot of my
constituents that they would like to see
a workable um bill I I feel like members
of this committee and people who came
today will into two camps they'll either
be wanting itl no changes can really fix
it for them and then others who want the
best product um to to come from
amendments um because I think we all
probably agree that an amendment is
necessary if we were to go forward with
it so I I'm not ready to vote on it
today I think many members of this
committee wouldn't be ready to vote on
it today um because an amendment could
make it workable and I think a lot of my
constituents would like to see an effort
to make this bill um as good as possible
all right anyone else Mr chair yes
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question well I
believe that this bill is not ready for
prime time and it sounds like it would
need a lot of amendments um and a lot of
work and a lot of time to get it to
where it could be possible or palatable
for the residents of the State of New
Hampshire and I'm thinking and the that
maybe this should have been a
constitutional amendment as cacr rather
than um just an um an LSR because that
way it it goes to the question goes to
the voters and they get to vote on it
thank you anyone else any other comments
yes represent stapon do it in a week
yeah thank you Mr chair
um I don't think I've had another bill
where I've had so many constituent and
uh other inputs
hundreds of emails uh dozens of
letters um on both sides of the issue so
I haven't made a count but uh you know
if it's 45 55 or 5050 or whatever it
might
be
um I I have trouble with this bill from
at least two points the insurance um
class ifying a suicide as not a
suicide um represents problems for the
insurance industry and life insurance
contracts I'm troubled with uh the lack
of attendance you know self-
Administration
um many of my constituents are opposed
this from ethical practical and even
moral standpoints and so am I and and I
believe that the Amendments aren't going
to change those
basic um Holdings and beliefs uh so I'm
ready to vote on on this
now um I have
experienced and been with close friends
and
relatives in the passing of their
lives and have supported them as much as
I could and I was very satisfied with
the state of pallative care and hospice
they know how to administrate the pain
medications to the point necessary until
the body gives up and systems
fail um I am a believer in the sanctity
of life from the moment of conception to
the moment of natural death and um there
there are many hard stories that have
touched the heart about pain and S
suffering um but I think we got to get
this right and
um and self
assisted or physician assisted suicide
is is not the answer I think we need to
concentrate on paliative care and
improving that and
education uh but I would be a no vote on
this bill in any case amendments are no
right anyone else wish to be heard yes
represent Alexander thank you um for
listening to me again I I think maybe
perhaps the best strategy would be for
the committee members that would like to
work on this bill they we interm study
it and allow the members this summer to
work on the bill because it seems like
not a single member is ready to vote Yes
on the bill today maybe from what I hear
so maybe the ones that would like to
work on the bill work on it over the
summer and then the ones that do not
want to work on the bill and will not be
voting for it take the summer off thank
you anyone else else wish to be heard
yes representative
tur yeah I just wanted to say um you
know and EO where Walt started uh sorry
representative Stapleton started um you
know if there's division on this and
there are potential amendments that may
or may not cure issues with the bill for
some or more of the members it sort of
feels like why wouldn't we finish that
process first and get to a place
where based on the things that people
know they want to potentially change
that we can evaluate that and and get I
don't think our goal is to get to the
place where everyone's in agreement it
gets to a place where we all feel like
we know what we would be voting on so I
would be supportive of continuing this
and and and hearing those amendments and
and then voting you know and seeing
where we stand as a group all right
anyone else uh uh representative Horan
um thank you very much first of all I
lifted this issue in my own life just a
few weeks ago and I know all 19 of my
colleagues on the committee have been
thinking and praying for me I'm thankful
for that but I think um regardless of
what happens to this bill we probably
need to raise public awareness of the
existing options for pallative and
hospice care which I think um maybe not
every family that's in crisis is uh is
what knows b as many knows about some of
the options that already exist under the
existing law so even if we pass this
today and it goes through it's still
like whatever the effective date is so
even then there'll be a period of time
where people are going to be going
through what my family went through so I
think um so I think this uh I think this
issue I mean I certainly certainly would
be better to like consider some
amendments and take take another few a
little more time to look at it but I
think even regardless of what happens um
I think there needs to be greater public
awareness of what they can do for their
family and friends when as happens to
everybody they reach they get near the
end of life so that's all right that's
my two cents so thank and also once
again thank thanks everybody in the
committee and many of the people who are
sitting in the audience too for their
support and I know we'll all need it
every the rest of us will all need that
same support at some point and I hope
hope I'll be able to pay pay pay that
back so thanks all right representative
Perez I
agree in any rate to try to EXA this in
less than a week from today
I do not
believe does it justice to be able to uh
get the amendments in that people want
and absorb the Amendments and then not
work on this until you know the towards
the end of the day in a week I think
it's way too soon all right all right so
anyone else wish to be heard yes
representative
Smith this is what the Democratic
process small the Democratic process is
all about it is listening to our
constituents it's listening to our
colleagues it's trying to find a way to
get us to yes whatever yes is um hearing
disperate
views and um it's never easy and we
don't always get it right the first time
I'm sorry to say but we try one of the
thoughts that keeps on coming back to me
is that um in the fall late fall um
UNH um which doesn't always get things
right either but nonetheless UNH
ran um an independent
poll uh h on this very
issue and when you look at the
results there are some really
interesting numbers that come up it's
the data that I'm always looking for but
isn't necessarily
reliable um and these aren't people who
have been
organized to write to us or to call us
um or doing it on their own these are
people who are called
blindly and uh and as their opinion and
when I look at the result and see that
over 70% of the citizens who were PED in
this state
support um end of
life options we're only talking about an
option here an option we're not talking
about any demanded um I was fascinated
to see that the North country had uh
something like 885 per I was really
surprised that it was so high and I
don't know why but um it might have to
do with the fact that they don't
necessarily have access the way those of
us in the southern part of the state do
to arrange of other services that we all
value Hospice pallative Care all of that
um gun owners over
70% support this and um I think that's
something that's really quite quite
interesting um to see um people who
identify
themselves as
religious they chose to identify
themselves as religious over 60% and
that
includes Protestants Jews and Roman
Catholics um now these aren't people who
were the as you are you are Jewish they
therefore how do you believe in the they
were asked to identify themselves and I
know I know when I do these polls I
don't like to tell very much about
myself but these are people who chose to
so my my point that I'm trying to make
is that this room has people who are
very caring and who have self- selected
to come here we have heard from people
who have self- selected to call us
sometimes a little late in the evening
and to write to us or to you know to
email us and then we hear from people
who were just a random group who seemed
to think that there is Merit in this and
that is
why I completely understand the
Divergent views I have no problem with
people with different views on this or
on anything else because it is the
Democratic way but I think we deserve we
I think we have an obligation to the 70
some OD percent of people who resp who
were asked and responded to a
poll to give this everything that we
can I think that on this bill and on a
number of other bills this committee's
been
rushed to make a decision before we
necessarily had an opportunity to weigh
all the pluses and minuses and I would
put this bill on that list um and think
I'd like to take a little more time
particularly because we have seen that
there's a lot of interest out there in
in the state on this and the one thing
we all have in common is that we were
all born and we will all die so this
affects everyone thank you Mr chair
thank you is anyone who hasn't spoken
I'm in on the committee that wishes to
be heard all right so what I'm going to
do uh then is I am going to uh delay a
vote on this matter because I think um
that representative Smith and
representative tur I agree with their
position that um we really we really
can't u i I speak as someone who is a
supporter of this bill I make it clear
that I'm a a strong supporter of this
bill could it be made better with some
amendments along the lines of what we've
talked about I think it could um and I
think we have an obligation to try to do
that I understand that there are some
people on the committee um uh who who
you know no matter uh who whose view is
that they could not support this bill uh
regardless of the Amendments and I
completely understand that and respect
their view on that um but I do think I I
don't think that there is a reason that
this bill needs to be postponed um you
know for interim study or something like
that the Amendments that I'm talking
about are not particularly uh uh uh
significant in the overall scheme of
things as I understand it although I was
never involved in this bill in my last
my first term as a legislator um my
understanding is that this this
something like this bill has gone
through um the legislature before and I
you know I I uh if people want more
details on that I would refer to people
who have been in the legislature longer
than I have and were on this committee
uh in earlier terms but I I guess what
I'm saying is it's this we are not uh
this isn't the the first go around on
this bill and there may need to be a a
few amendments but I think they're
relatively discreet um I think we can
get them done hopefully we can get them
done it's on the schedule to be uh for
the continued executive session
next uh uh Wednesday afternoon if it
turns out that the you know the uh
amendments are more complicated uh than
we thought or something it's possible we
could end up rescheduling that to I
guess it would have to be two weeks
later because they're we're not going to
be sitting the week of school vacation
um but it but at any event I I feel
quite confident that we can have a vote
on this bill at least by uh early March
so for that reason I'm going to uh we're
not I'm not going to uh take a vote on
this bill now so then like next what I'd
like to do is go on to uh our other
agenda and I'm going to turn to uh house
bill 14 1412 dealing with court reporter
deregulation and repres recognized
representative cutab for a motion I move
OTP is there a second I'll
second all right um representative kab
would you like to speak to your motion
would you like me to speak to it
whatever um I'll just be really short on
it I you know I I'm not sure the need
since we don't have court reporters
inside of the court anymore I'm not sure
the need to license it I you know
they're being used privately by private
attorneys and I think the private
attorneys can evaluate the people that
we're using there was they I mean they
flat out told us themselves that there
are no more court reporters inside of
the court so I think we're licensing
something that's being used privately
and that it can be handled privately and
doesn't need a public license thank you
right any other people wish to be
heard oh yes I'm sorry represent Smith
I'm sorry okay thank you very much I I
wait to be asked um I'm interested to
hear what um the maker of the motion
said because I happen to think she's
terrific um but the art argument that if
the if they're not in the
courts we shouldn't be involved kind of
doesn't make any sense because to me
unless it can be explained we license a
lot of people who are not in the courts
we we license people we license people
who cut hair we license teachers we
license all kinds of people the fact
that they're not in the court is
irrelevant they provide a service that
is relied upon um in the judicial
process and um as for me I'd like to
make sure that there people who are
trained and
qualified and
um follow particular standards and so
that I know that their
certification
um of of particular procedures is valid
so um while I completely
respect
um the maker of the motion I just have
to disagree on the conclusion and I
would vote um against this motion anyone
else wishes to speak representative tur
yeah ju just one thing that I came away
with from our hearing was um the folks
that would be I think given Relief by
removing this licensing process
licensing requirement the process they
have to go through and the fees that
they have to pay we're all here in
support
of continuing that license my
understanding I think I even asked is
there anyone that they know of that from
their constituent group that that might
feel that they should get that this
should be done away with and they said
no and and anyone who's being excluded
from the profession um because of the
licensing requirement didn't come before
our group to to explain that so I don't
understand why we would get rid of a
licensing requirement that nobody's
advocating for us to not have all right
anyone else wish to be heard on so I
guess I would just um I I have I have
some sort of long history on on this and
I won't I won't bore you now um with the
with the details of the long history but
what I would what I would say is
this all of the arguments
that you heard by the by the people who
testified in support of continuing to
have regulation of court reporters all
of those arguments were the very same
arguments that were made to the Supreme
Court back in 2004 and 2005 for why the
court system should not get should not
eliminate using Court
stenographers we had the the record will
be it the record will not be secure
there will be um it'll be terrible uh we
need the court reporters and I have to
say I I want I as I said I don't want to
get into a lot of
detail I was one of the judges on The
Superior Court who agreed with those
arguments I would have been you know 20
years ago I would have been saying the
same thing that we heard from
representative shirtliff about this is
terrible if we get rid of the court
report orders the records will not the
record will not be accurate we can't
just use uh people uh listening uh
people uh monitoring tape recorders
it'll be absolutely awful um and I
thought the Supreme Court was just at
you know this was going to be a
catastrophic
mistake the reality is I was
wrong that the the the court system
began you replaced the court reporters
in fact they brought a lawsuit it went
to the Supreme Court it was a three to
two decision in the Supreme Court with
with substitute judges back in long
before I got to the Supreme Court it was
a big
deal um but in fact the reality is that
having
non-licensed uh Court monitors who who
run the run the the tape recording
machine in the court system and the and
the the the the tapes get electronically
sent to an outfit in Arizona they've
been using that for years I just
recently checked with the clerk of the
Supreme Court to make sure they were
still using the same outfit they send it
to an outfit in Arizona which who who
does the
transcripts it works fine and it saved
the judicial branch a substantial amount
of
money there is no reason for the state
to continue to be involved in the
regulation of what we could if we were
on if we wanted to be accurate we would
say this is a bill regarding non-court
reporters because they don't do anything
in the court
anymore so the analogy I would ask you
to draw is it's it continuing to
regulate the court reporters would be
like suppose suppose that that we said
well major league baseball players don't
have to be licensed but if you're
playing in the minor leagues you got to
have a license I think most people would
say why what why why does that make any
sense if we
don't
the the continuing lure of court
reporters it seems to me it is simply a
matter of of sort of trying to eliminate
competition trying to make it trying to
make uh prevent people who who um would
would do would do outside of the Court
essentially what the what we refer to
now the court monitors the people who
use the tape recorders do inside the
court prevent them from doing that and
right now under the law they are they
are prohibited from that because they
can't if they um if they uh try to
provide Court Reporting Services it's
actually a crime it becomes a Class A
misdemeanor it's as much as I love and
respect the court reporters I I mean I
think that was we we all in the in the
court system at the time on the superior
court at least we all were you know we
we felt terrible for what happened to
the court reporters but the reality is
that there is no legitimate reason for
continuing to regulate that if they want
to have their certification they can
still there's a National Association of
court reporters they can still you know
tell prospective lawyers that might want
to use a deposition someone for a
deposition I'm a member of the National
Association of court reporters I've been
certified by them and maybe lawyers will
say I that's what I want but there
should be no reason that somebody says
who has who is willing to uh provide
those Services perhaps for less money um
by by tape recording the uh the uh the
deposition shouldn't be able to do that
if they want to so that's that's I'm
sorry I've spoken longer than I intended
to but that's why I think uh this we
ought to OTP this
Bill yes representative Stapleton I was
originally opposed to this feeling that
we were pulling the rug out from
underneath these people who do a fine
job and what they do even if it's
outside of the court and I thought about
it a long time and you know technology
is replacing the need and the
function um you know I'm a railroad guy
I used to be a member of the order of
railroad
telegraphers well if you could find a
telegraph key in a railroad environment
anymore they'd be doing something
probably a museum so you know all
Industries and crafts move forward with
technology that's a basis of improvement
and professional associations um
industrial associations will fill the
Gap that uh certification withdrawn uh
will will leave them so I'm I'm good
with the U the OTP anyone else wish to
be heard yes representative
L um I just want to say that I think
first of all their lure is very
important um because there is not many
court reporters that are out there
anymore within our state and the ones
that we do have um they need to be
valued and I think at the same time that
it's it's very important yes technology
is is great but at the same time um they
have actually on to um had education
within this to do that and it's just
like anything doing away with jobs um
you think about it um it's their
livelihood that some of them have been
it doing it for 35 years some of us that
came to testify so I think we really
need to think about it um strongly when
we make our decision thank you all right
anyone else wish to be heard yes
representative manx thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to point out um the fiscal
note um says that the impact is expected
to be less than $10,000 in each of the
fiscal years from 2024 through
2027 so whatever the impact is on the
court system it's less than $10,000 a
year now um it doesn't specify a more
specific dollar figure so I don't know
whether it's closer to the $2,000 range
or the $9,000 range I don't but um it
seems that at least the fiscal impact on
the court is fairly
insignificant representative H it's not
on the court I'm inclined to leave the
law the way it is um there's a obviously
here in conquer there certain hostility
to professional licensure in general but
I think there's I think there's still
some value into having licensing and
perhaps we may even need more regulation
of these companies which uh transcribe
the recordings because we certainly like
we have another bill in this committee
which hinges a lot on like what what's
on court transcripts so it's there's
some Val there's some value I think in
making sure that the even if we are
sending them off to Arizona or wherever
have these things transcribed that they
be uh properly properly transcribed so I
think we're I think we'd be losing
something by just eliminating uh this
license even though it is a profession
that's on its way out the time may have
passed it by but I think it still has
its place so I'm going to be voting
against uh the ought to pass which I
guess is what the motion will be all
right represent Smith
thank you Mr chair I just want to make
one correction the um it would not be
the court that would have less than
$10,000 uh dollar um a year in each of
the future fiscal years it's the office
of professional liur and certification
that's where um the license is a process
not in the court anyone else wish to
have anything to say on this bill right
I think we're ready to uh call the role
the motion is uh
OTP Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip
yes rep gson yes clerk kab votes yes rep
Perez yes rep Smith no rep Horgan no rep
D Lorenzo no rep Kenny no rep paage no
rep Divine no rep lonza no rep Thanos no
repur no rep Ming no chairman Lynn yes
motion bails 10 to 10 is there another
motion
well um I'll I'll make a motion of um
itl there second
all right any further
discussion seeing none I guess we're
ready to call the role on
itl Vice chairman Wallace No rep
Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman
yes
yes did excuse me it should be no no
okay rep
Stapleton
no rep trip no rep gson
no parab votes no rep Perez no rep Smith
yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep
page rep Divine yes rep uh lonza yes rep
Manos yes repur yes rep Ming yes
chairman
no motion veils 10 to
10 all right so it'll go on the calendar
without
recommendation
um all right and
um uh representative kab could I ask you
to write the report for the OTP uh and
how about for uh itl
um
anyone interested
in um I'll I'll do it
okay
what oh no I don't do that I don't twist
arms nobody's hand went up so next we
don't do that on our side of the
aisle
really uh at least I don't do it next I
um like to turn to
cac12 and um I'm going to uh
recognize
myself uh for a motion I have an
amendment which I think has been passed
out to everyone has has everyone does
everyone have it I have not seen it it
might just be that I've missed it has
anyone else seen it we had passed
it it's where oh I'm I'm sorry so
there's these are extra copies but I
thought it would it got passed around to
everyone
it's
0524 right no I have not seen this
um I'm sorry I thought I no I thought I
not I thought I sent this out the night
before
last
yeah we would like them I don't I am I
the only one who doesn't have
it do you have
it thanks oh here okay everybody
okay so that so the where you'll see
that the uh the the wait wait so you're
so you made the motion for the uh
adoption of the amendment was it who
seconded that right was that rep Wallace
did you second sure
okay
would you like to explain it to us to
read the whole thing no absolutely so so
you you may
recall you may recall that um
representative Maguire had a the
original bill was
to change the definition of
cherish from what it meant in
1784 to what it means today um and the
purpose of this amendment is as I think
I may have mentioned at the at the
hearing on
this I understood the intent to to be
can't to just be very C with due
deference to representative Maguire who
I like a lot um I just I thought it was
just a little too cutesy I mean it one
of the one of the main reasons that I
thought that was that the the the
definition of cherish in 1784 is not all
that different from the definition of
cherish today is a little bit different
but not much um and what it seemed to me
what the purpose the entire purpose of
the Constitutional amendment was was you
know to to
uh to basically say to to overrule The
Claremont decision and to essentially
say to the Supreme Court whatever you
thought cherish meant based on the 17084
definition it doesn't mean that anymore
and so you're you know it's time to uh
it's time to overrule Claremont um I
just
felt rather than be sort of cutesy about
it why not just draft an amendment that
said that basically says that that's
what you're doing and so this the
language that that I propose to add to
cac12 um says this provided further
however that the duty to cherish the
interest of literature and the sciences
and all seminaries and public schools
does not require the state to provide
funding for public or private schools or
other educational institutions at any
particular level the legislator shall
have exclusive authority to determine
the amount of such funding the purposes
for which such expend shall be uh made
and the sources of funding thereof
including the extent to which counties
towns cities and unincorporated places
shall contribute uh funding for these
purposes and no court shall have
jurisdiction to review set aside or
modify any decisions made by the
legislature with regard to these matters
so that I mean that's basically that
that sort of says
what what I think the law was uh before
Claremont and what I think the law
should be today yeah I would like to
congratulate the chair for being
absolutely and completely
honest in this amendment and I too like
representative Maguire and we have
worked together on many uh many issues
not exactly this one um because I happen
to believe in three branches of
government legislative executive and
judicial even though the judicial branch
Now does not happen to have the benefit
of the former Chief Justice there are
other moderately competent
people um in the um in the judicial
branch and I also believe that there is
nothing that is more
important in a democ Democratic small D
Democratic Society then public
education um I could not possibly
support any amendment that removes one
branch of the government from something
as important as public
education and I would suggest on this
one um Mr chair there's probably no need
to have extensive debate because I think
we can probably predict what is going to
happen um on the vote and we might as
well just go right ahead to the vote for
those people who don't believe that the
judicial branch should have any role in
protecting access in a Democratic
Society to public education and those
people who do and will vote and then
we'll go on from there and probably no
positions will be changed thank you
anyone else uh yes representative Greece
just for the record we have a Republic
small R uh form of government that uses
Democratic principles small D but uh
that's all just point of contention
other um anyone else uh yes
representative Staples well thank you Mr
chair and thank you for bringing forth
this amendment um I was uncertain as to
how to parse this out and where to go
with it but if we look at the conval and
the ran lawsuit decisions they squarely
put the obligation um for um the matter
into the
legislature and this amendment um states
that so I thought we brought two maybe
opposing sides somewhat together with
the amendment thank you and um I'm good
with the amendment all right anyone else
wish to be heard representative organ
well I guess ran Smith pretty much said
it all but that last sentence um I don't
totally don't see how that could work I
mean I guess a constitutional provision
can't be unconstitutional but I'm not
sure how given what we say about the
courts and the rest of the Constitution
how we can shut them out of that one uh
subject area I mean the we had the
Claremont decision and the other ones
but the problem that it's not really the
Court's fault problem is the legislature
has been refusing to follow the
Constitution and also if you're talking
about funding for any level that's kind
of strange but also like you're leaving
out the uh of course you're leaving out
the education Freedom account or School
voucher uh providers so we're not
although I guess you know so we're not
we're not going to be obligated to fund
that program either if we pass this
Constitutional Amendment which I mean
that doesn't necessarily bother me
personally but I think so I think think
this uh Amendment it's it's it's
interesting but I don't think it uh just
totally doesn't work for me especially
that last sentence just I that's going
to create massive confusion and finally
I'm sort of pleasantly surprised at
least that uh they wanted to stick with
the 2024 definition of cherish usually
they're talking about how people thought
of things in the 18th century as well as
the 21st century it's because they want
us to go back to the 21st to the 18th
century so at least at least that part
of debate is somewhat encouraging but
I'm I'm still like a you I'm I'm still
not supportive of this amendment at all
so but it's it's a it's very it's very
interesting though but thanks right any
other any any other comments uh
representative line I'm almost afraid to
say it
but don't we open the door to when we
start playing cutesy with you know
passing potential bills like this and
changing words like cherish and then
just bringing them up to date couldn't
one you know later on turn around and
bring another bill forward say with the
right to bear arms and say this phrase
does not jive with what wants what what
people want to happen now so let's
change it now and make it more of what's
politically correct in
2024 as opposed to what was politically
correct in 1776 or whatever
why would we be looking at that that's
where I'm kind of having a problem with
this this is a play on words and I don't
think we should be even addressing it in
this room that's where I stand okay
anyone else wish to be
heard yes
repres so I really don't like that the
initial bill
wasn't more clear on what the intent was
and I do like that the amendment is
clear on the intent on what the intent
is I don't think that it's fair to put
something potentially out to voters that
they're not going to
understand what it even means when
you're putting something out there I
mean I can't imagine getting this as a
voter and and seeing okay we're going to
change the word cherish to cherish
voters are going to be so confused going
why are we changing a word to the same
word so I do like that the amendment
makes
clear what the intent actually
is
however I think that we've always kind
of valued education and I'm not sure
that I like that
it's solely leaving it up
without anybody being able to oversee it
I'm not sure how I feel about it but I I
do like that the amendment is kind of
more clear on it um and I
do I guess I'm I'm kind
of a little little bit uh unsure where
to go on this one thanks anyone else
wish to be heard representative D
Lorenzo thank you Mr chair you know this
is confusing the bill is confusing the
amendment is a little bit more clear but
when
we when a secretary of state draws up
the question on the ballots what exactly
is it going to say it's so it's it's
it's on there it's on it's on the it's
in the bill what it will
say right here
I don't see it printed
out okay oh I
see okay so that's it that's fine thank
you anyone else wish to be heard so you
know the only other the only other thing
that I would say on this is and
I you know I I understand uh both
representative kutab and representative
Smith's U point about the
court my problem is and this is the this
really is the I think is the heart of
the Claremont the heart of the Claremont
matter if we don't do something like
this this will never end the important
thing I think the the most disturbing
part about Claremont is that by creating
this this sort of affirmative right this
affirmative constitutional right that
anybody can exercise
the funding thing will never end
there'll there's this this litigation
now it'll go to the Supreme Court the
Supreme Court will do what whatever they
let let's
assume that that the Supreme Court
affirms the trial court and says uh I
think what it was $77,000 in per student
or something is what a minimum uh
require that's that that'll be good
until somebody gets the idea that they
should be spending more and then
there'll be another lawsuit and it'll go
on and on and and on and that's why it
just seems to
me the legislature is the body that is
rep that is elected and representative
of the people and should be the ones
that make these decisions so that's why
I think this is important um but anyway
you know understand this is as as I've
said to my co as I say it public there's
been nobody in leadership on the on my
side of the aisle has been sort of
trying to Strongarm anybody on this so I
encourage all of you to vote your
conscience on
this Mr chair can I say one quick sure
absolutely to representative D Lorenzo's
Point um I don't know if it matters but
in the amendment the new language on the
final page that inserts your language
from page two isn't bolded so I don't
know if the amendment is fully clear
that it's also adding that in what would
be on the
ballot that I mean that's a good point I
think from my understanding of Prior
Constitutional Amendments that they
generally don't on the ballot itself
they wouldn't put that in I think that's
I think that's the way they they
typically do it okay I was just
questioning the the form of the
amendment not not the content to the
amendment right now I hear you all right
um anyone else wish to be heard all
right so I guess I would ask the uh
clerk to call the role well we can do it
by on the amend let's call the role on
the amendment okay all right sure that's
fine no that's
fine all right so on the emotion of
adopting Amendment
0524 Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander
no rep Andrews
yes rep testerman yes rep steton yes rep
trip yes rep gon
yes clerk could have votes yes rep Perez
yes rep Smith
no rep Horgan no rep D Lorenzo no rep
Kenny no rep Paige no rep Divine no rep
lonza no rep Manos no repur no rep Ming
no motion fails 9 to1 oh whoops sorry
chairman Lynn sorry chairman Lynn that's
all right yes
okay all right so motion fails 9
to1 okay and then
um
yes I would like to make a motion on
cac12
yes
uh that's a good question that you know
representative
Reon that's interesting I I would have
to check with the clerk on that
because we were really voting only on
the amendment right um and if I can help
to I think me may want to change their
vote between the amendment and the in
the actual underlying bill as
well representative Alexander so what do
you mean by
that so you would like to go I mean I
think we should have a full vote on the
OTP motion yeah I'm happy then to
withdraw my I'm I'm happy to withdraw my
motion if you want to go straight to
OTP on the original then it would have
to be that's the only thing before us Y
and I know I and I think I understand
where representative Alexander's coming
from because I think some people that
voted for the amendment might not be
voting for The OTP on the underlying
bill um all right so can I ask you to
call the role
please on the motion of OTP Vice
chairman Wallace yes BR Alexander
yes rep Andrews
no rep esterman
yes rep Stapleton
yes rep trip
yes rep gon
yes cler votes no rep Perez
yes rep Smith
no rep Horgan no rep D Lorenzo no rep
Kenny no rep paage no rep Divine no rep
lonza no rep Manos no repur no rep Ming
no chairman Lynn
yes motion fails 8
to2 all right now do we
have Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion yes I really don't want to make a
motion but I'm going
to uh Mr chair I would move itl on
C
cr12 is there a
second second by representative
Kenny who second representative Kenny
thank you any further
discussion then I think we can call the
rooll on the uh
I
Vice chairman Wallace No rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes
rep
Stapleton yes rep trip
no rep gon
yes Clark could have votes yes rep Perez
no rep Smith
yes rep Horgan yes and rep D Lorenzo yes
rep Kenny yes rep Paige yes rep Divine
yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes repur
yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
no motion fails 16 a motion passes 16
to4
all right I will um write the blow
excuse me the
report all right
um
and and I I guess um if there's going to
be a Minority Report I will write it I'm
not sure whe there will be or not but
unless unless somebody else wants to
write The Minority
Report not seeing anyone okay I'm
yeah all right um let's uh go to uh 1169
discrimination based on
hairstyles and
um do I have a motion on
that I'll move
OTP um I'll second who was that was that
D
Lorenzo kab oh kab okay no toab and Lynn
and Lynn yeah OTP on
1169 uh representative kab do you want
to speak to uh your
motion no that's okay all right anyone
anyone yes represent Alexander thank you
Mr chair I have a huge problem with this
bill I think that the Human Rights
Commission has this right when they say
that when you add more language it
actually does a disservice to people
that are being discriminated against by
adding more specific language than
leaving the whole ethnicity I think the
Human Rights Commission is right so I'm
definitely voting against that motion
thank you all right anyone else wish to
be
heard right then i' ask the clerk to
call the rooll please Vice chairman
Wallace yes rep Alexander no rep Andrews
yes rep testerman yes rep Stapleton yes
rep trip no
rep
gon
oh um clerk kab votes
yes rep Perez yes rep Smith
yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep Paige yes rep Divine yes
rep lonza yes rep Manos yes repur yes
Rett Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes
17-2 can that go on consent anybody have
an objection to yeah can we leave that
on regular Calendar please all right
thank you
regular um we writing a Minority
Report I'll I'll write a Minority Report
thank you all right um so
who um who wants to write the majority
report can I uh solicit U I'm a
co-sponsor may I still of course yes
okay yes I will do it so all right so
majority will be uh representative D
Lorenzo and the minority will be
representative
Alexander long
here
um all right next um House Bill uh
1220 um and I believe representative
Ming you have a an amendment is that
correct so do you want to move your
Amendment okay yeah um so the amendment
is 2024 041 15h and again this is to oh
the the the initial bill is is um to
remove the collection so we just you you
so you move your amendment is that I
move my Amendment okay sorry yes and
then second is there a
second wa Mr chair just a point of
clarification the motion is OTP and he's
moving an amendment OTP thank you that's
I just I move a to pass with Amendment
2024 041 15h all right and is there a
second I
second yes it was distributed I believe
but there are additional copies think so
yeah yeah it was
distributed this was I think it was
distributed quite a while
ago um I'm sorry who made the second on
that I did you
okay
all right sorry represent M you wish to
speak to your amendment I I can just do
it really quickly so again this the
underlying bill is to remove the
collection of race and An ancestry from
Marriage applications um and the
amendment is to additionally move the
level of
Education that that's pretty much it all
right anyone else that wish to be heard
on uh the amend
yeah oh yes representative Perez I just
want to say that once again I think for
future for future Generations it is
important to have the
ethnicity on the marriage certificate so
that when they look back when names have
changed over and over and over again and
they have no idea when they look back
they can see where their
relatives came from because a lot of
things come up later
or I think for medical reasons if
nothing else it should be on there all
right anyone else um wish to be yes I
don't think it's really necessary to
have the um ethnicity on the marriage
ancestry on the marriage report because
uh DNA is widely available for everyone
thank you
right other anyone else wish to be heard
all right so this is going to be a vote
on the amendment I would propose to do
that by show of hands unless somebody
objects all right so um show of hands
then for those in favor of the amendment
please raise your
hand those
opposed all right uh who I'm sorry we
have uh two so it's representative
Andress and uh representative uh
are opposed so what 17 17 to two wait
no Alexander Alexander's not in the room
oh I'm sorry I didn't see him
leave sorry 17 to
two all right so now um we're on to uh
the main uh motion of ought to pass as
amended does anyone wish to speak
further on the uh motion of
otpa seeing none I would ask the clerk
then to call the role on the otpa motion
and that was moved by rep Ming and
seconded by rep
Smith yes yes it was thank you so
much Vice chairman Wallace yes rep uh
rep Andrews no rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep
gon yes clerk attab votes yes rep Perez
no rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep
dorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep pagee yes
rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
rep teror yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes
motion passes
17-2 all right um can that go on the
consent calendar anyone object to it
being on
consent all right so it'll go okay all
right no they'll go on the regular
calendar all right um Regular all right
um minity rep all right so
representative Ming you will write will
you write the majority report yes and
representative Perez you're going to
write the
minority all
right all right um so what I would um
what I'm going to do uh on House Bill
1432 um I
think we're by we're yeah I'm going to
recess the executive session on that
because I think we're basically in the
same position on that bill as we were on
1283 um there are some amendments that
have been um uh sort of baned about I
mean I haven't nothing's been filed yet
but um there have been some
amendments um that I I think ought to be
considered before uh before we have a a
further discussion on the bill um and so
that uh I'm going to recess the uh the
hearing ing on that and we'll take that
up um next Wednesday if we have time and
if we don't have time then because we're
we're too busy then we'll move it over
to to after that but I think that's I
think that's really an important bill
and I'm hoping I know that there have
been some uh uh some people have
expressed an in uh a opposition to the
bill initially but I'm hoping that maybe
with the Amendments we may be able to
get um we may be able to come to more of
a consensus on it uh then next I'm going
to turn to um House Bill uh
1475 and
um I guess I'll uh recognize myself um
with regard to that and uh move uh in
expedient to legislate is there a second
I second all right seconded by
representative cutab
uh and so uh let me just um
State briefly as I can why I think itl
is the
appropriate the the person who who
testified about these slap lawsuits I
believe he was an attorney from
Massachusetts um was obviously very
knowledgeable in this area and um
apparently has drafted these kind of
bills for other states um I looked at
the bill I looked at the uh the bill
very carefully um and I I know I asked
representative Paige if he had a chance
to look at if he would have a chance to
look at it and what his impression was
and I'm going to ask him about that in a
minute but my my impression
about the bill was that although there
was talk about this making substantial
substantive changes to the
law it really doesn't if you look if you
look at the bill what it essentially
does is in lawsuits that might be
characterized as um being brought
against somebody either as a claim or a
counter claim um to try to
prevent them from exercising their
rights of expression all this bill does
really is to say that in those kind of
cases there can
be kind of an expedited motion to
dismiss and a requirement that the
plaintiff in those kind of cases come
forth
with with um its evidence if you will at
an earlier stage than might otherwise be
the case under the normal rules of the
Court it does doesn't change in any way
the substantive law um and
so you know is that a particular value
to have to be able to resolve cases more
quickly in some
circumstances you know
arguably but the problem
is I have we didn't really hear any
evidence that there's that this is a
problem in New Hampshire that people are
bringing you know these kind of lawsuits
uh to stop public participation in New
Hampshire I didn't hear any evidence
about that in the time that I you know
spent it as a judge I didn't see that
this was uh I'm not I'm not saying that
there was never a case like this I don't
know I I can't remember one off hand but
um it certainly wasn't something that
was sort of you know an epidemic that
requires some some uh specialized
procedures so for those reasons I I just
think
uh it ain't broke don't fix it that's
but representative Paige I I I asked you
if uh if you have a different view I'm
I'm all ears so as a former Elementary
School teacher to say I didn't do my
homework very well I will say that now
um my initial sort of 30,000 foot view
where there's some there may have been
some sort of jurisdictional issues in
terms of
um State claims and feder court that oh
the FED no you're right is a real issue
that issue with with this that I'm not
sure has been resolved so um but I I
concur that I don't see this as a
necessary U action if that's what I'm
understanding you say but no and you
rais a very valid point there's some
language in there about what the what
what the federal courts would have to do
that I'm not sure would would be
constitutional uh under the supremacy
clause but I but you know that's that
that's so that's another issue but I
think the main reason for me is I just
don't see that this is necessary anyone
yes representative Perez I just want to
say these things are happening maybe
they didn't when you were on the bench
but these things are happening
especially in small towns that people
are lawsuits are being pushed against
people um and I think this is not the
wording perhaps or it needs to be redone
but we do have you know people that are
municipalities are going after people
and putting things on them for no
Justified reason so all right anyone
else wish to be heard on
this all right uh then I the motion is
itl and I would ask the uh clerk to call
a rooll please Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip
yes rep gon yes Clerk have votes yes rep
Perez yes rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes
rep De Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep
page yes rep Divine yes rep lonza yes
rep Manos yes rep T yes rep Ming yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 20
to0 consent uh consent all right and I
will uh write the report
um all right next
um oh
1412 you and K I think yeah
right uh all right on House Bill
1603 uh this is the
um
this is a bill that uh would I I guess
the intent was to um
prohibit uh municipalities or local
governmental bodies
from
passing passing laws that would prevent
would prohibit women from being topless
uh where men were allowed to be topless
that uh that if I recall from
representative hein's testimony that was
the basic purpose of the bill as you may
know there was a Supreme Court decision
that said that that was that was it
wasn't unconstitutional to do that um so
um do I do I have a motion on that
bill anyone want all right well then I
will draws the short
[Laughter]
STW all right uh motion itl
all right is there a
second I second all right second all
right um so all right um representative
Stapleton do you wish to be heard at all
on your
motion well un I got a note here um
problematic and
unintended results um and maybe when we
have like in 396 uh enabled Separation
by the Sexes this might be
running um contrary to that and creates
a
problem so I'm
might on it
um anyone else wish to be heard on uh
yes well two good reasons it one is it
goes far beyond um course I was not at
the hearing but it goes far beyond what
apparently was now former representative
hein's original intent but also the way
it's worded I'm not usually these well
it's probably in the wrong committee too
probably should have been a municipal
and County government but that's fine we
can handle it but the talks about the
unincorporated places they don't can't
do anything on their own the County
government stands in place of the uh
unincorporate place and usually I think
the language probably been more
appropriate is a political subdivision
that then that that also takes in school
districts and Village districts which
might also want to discriminate against
people on the basis of race or sex so
like aside from aside from the fact I
think the basic idea is not a great one
it's even if you like the idea it's not
really a well- worded way to do it so
all right thanks um anyone else who
should be heard on this
bill all right then I guess we're ready
to uh call the role the motion is itl on
House Bill
16003 Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip
yes rep gon yes clerk have votes yes rep
Perez yes rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes
rep De Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep
Peach yes rep Divine yes rep
Manos yes rep lonza yes rep turer yes
rep Ming yes chairman Lynn yes motion
passes 20
consent
and all right and uh representative
Stapleton could I ask you to write the
report thank
you that's it that's probably right
yes all right um next I'm going to turn
to House Bill
1037 and um I recognize representative
tur for a motion thank you Mr chairman
uh I had distributed an amendment to
this bill it is
0698 H um and I'd like to make the
motion to
otpa um 1037 with that Amendment all
right is there a
second seconded by um seconded by
um representative
Smith is it
7:13
699 yeah it's a 1037 is the bill and
0698 is the amendment I sent it around
in paper form and I emailed it yesterday
but uh I have extra copies of that if
anyone needs
it hang
on
sh
all right um represent would you like to
speak to your motion uh yeah that's
probably a good idea um so uh this uh
Amendment actually modifies the bill
very significantly um it basically takes
out the the main Clause of the original
Bill and replaces it with um
modification to the language that that
essentially uh only changes two words in
the um in the underlying law as it
stands um which seems fairly minor it
but it does have real um implications
and I think benefits for uh the way that
this works currently um I will
say um the reason for this as we went
around the discussion there was there
was a statement that um
that we that the the the idea that a an
organization manufacturer dealer that
that hasn't committed um any crimes
should should not be pierced in this
immunity um I will say there's a lot
that could be said I'm going to try and
avoid saying most of it but we'll answer
questions
um there was the Chester arms case
Supreme Court settlement just a couple
of weeks earlier than this hearing that
um spoke that that modified or or at
least clarified some of the Clauses in
the provision that this was relating to
um and and
um I think in a nutshell the the the the
thought behind this um is that the way
it stands right now a civil liability uh
case brought um can be only pierced
using results of a completely different
case
um which would be a Civ a criminal
proceeding against um the manufacturer
manufacturer or um a dealer of of the
weapons so there would have to be a
criminal case brought and a criminal
case decided and then the results of
that would have bearing on whether a
civil case could be brought um and
basically the change from the language
of convicted of to that committed brings
the requirements to understand whether
or not um those entities committed um an
underlying felonious act would be heard
as part of the civil suit rather than
hinging on an external
um an external lawsuit that's not really
part of the the the Civil proceeding um
and I will say
um I I will I will give deference I'm
not saying I want to make clear
representative Lynn did not say he
supports in any way this but helped um
think through the the concept underlying
this so did OLS that essentially when
you do that you also change the standard
of of proof um because a civil
proceeding has a preponderance of
evidence standard whereas a criminal
proceeding has a Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt standard so it's not saying that
you don't have to have committed a a um
felonious act in order to in order to
pierce theun just it just it puts the
standard in alignment with the Civil
proceeding that this bill that this um
RSA speaks to so I'll stop there and
there may be questions all right so um
so anyone else uh wish to be heard so I
guess what I would say is I I was happy
to work with with uh representative uh
tur on the on the amendment he he he
asked and I thought I had I thought I
could be helpful but I what I would say
and I say this very strongly is um
representative tur makes what in my view
is like a completely horrible bill into
only a very bad bill um uh uh and it
does make it does make a very
significant change in the law as be uh
because as as he said it would
significantly weaken the Firearms
immunity uh statute because it would
instead of having to uh have a
conviction that's already in place
beyond a reasonable doubt this would
allow somebody to prove in the civil
case that there was a crime that there
was a that the dealer committed some
kind of a crime um this
I can't emphasize strongly enough with
or without the amendment this bill is a
is the beginning of a death Nell to the
Firearms industry so um I uh I urge um I
urge people to vote against the
amendment and then against the
underlying
Bill representative
stapon thank you Mr chair um
I have difficulty getting my head around
that in spite of good attempt by my
colleague to explain it um I got the
difference between a civil and criminal
liability but I still puzzled as to why
that those are connected in this
instance um example might be helpful but
I can't conceive of one
um I just because I don't understand it
I I can't vote for the for the Amendment
with without a lot of additional thought
and I haven't got the time for that so
I've got to oppose the amendment all
right any anyone else wish to be heard
on the
amendment I I have to agree with you
representative Lynn um this is a back
door I've been saying it all along and
you talk about I had over
emails against this
bill all right any other comment all
right so we're voting on the amendment
only um and do we uh I think we probably
ought to do this by roll call okay on
the amendment Vice chairman Wallace No
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep stepleton no rep trip
no rep gon no clerk attab votes no rep
Perez rep
Smith
rep Horgan yes rep dorenzo yes rep Kenny
yes rep Paige yes rep
Divine yes rep
Manos yes repur
yes call me sorry rep Lanza um
yes rep Ming
yes chairman Lynn no
adoption fails 10 to
10 all right
um are we G to vote on the underp now
first oh um oh that no that's right we
probably should yeah right so um
representative t a uh hang on
can we move to itl the uh uh initial
bill yeah I I think I think we have to
do
OTP
Mr chair could I ask for ad oh excuse me
got so excited there could I ask for
advice certainly of course is that
allowed the the importance of the
presence of this industry in the state
is not to be denied there are a lot of
jobs it affects the whole state economy
this is not a little Fly by Night
operation
and that is very
important there are just as there are on
many bills that we have in this
committee
there
are difficult decisions that have to be
made in terms of
balancing the pluses and the minuses the
goods and the bads and violating or
dealing with what I'm going to
call oh I don't want to call it that
what kind of
preconditioned positions on
bills um let me give you just one
example and I hope no one's going to
groan and
moan um when I first was here the
presence of the
NRA was incredibly important for many
reasons including the way they
contributed to the cost of so many of
our colleagues campaigns
that has now changed over the
years and it's relevant because some of
our reactions are conditioned on past
realities I
personally do not want to see an
important
industry forced out of the
state I personally believe that as a
country we have a
problem
with the way our Firearms are available
to so many people it happens just
yesterday that apparently as part of
celebrating the Super Bowl it's
important to use Firearms I know and
everyone in this room knows that no
manufacturer of firearm arms want them
to be used that way I don't have any
question about that and I would imagine
that in another environment those
manufacturers would be willing to stand
up and say
that I think that somewhere there must
be a way for us to address the problem
of the misuse of
firearms
without
hurting an important
industry I don't know what that answer
is
but my problem is I don't want to
vote Yes on this bill I don't think it's
a good bill and I will say that
understanding that this is being taped
and it can now be used against me but
there's no
way that I could vote
either way I guess is what my problem is
and so what I'm wondering is would the
committee consider the
possibility of
us sending this
bill to interim
study to see if maybe we could come up
with a way that honors the import
importance of the industry in the
state while recognizing that
missuse is not in anybody's
interest I don't know if there's a way
to do that but I don't think anybody who
who who respects the
industry wants to see people at a Super
Bowl kids at a Super Bowl
shot at or killed or whatever and I I
really believe that so is there is there
some way that we can come up with a
brilliant idea and could we do it by um
interim studying this
bill I well if if a motion is
possible at this point I've now lost
track representative Bon's probably
right on it I've lost track track of
exactly where we are in parliamentary
procedure but if there were a
time when I could make that motion I
would um and uh rather than find myself
and others in a position of having to
vote for a
bill
that doesn't necessarily
accomplish what we want to
accomplish and it's a problem and I need
help so I guess my my sense is I think
we do uh U I think we do need to vote on
OTP and then if there's an itl motion on
itl but the other thing I would the
other thing I would say representative
Smith is I think at least I'm speaking
for myself here I don't know if my
colleagues agree I just feel so strongly
that this bill is is just that this bill
needs to die FR to be candid about it
that I don't think that there's
anything that I can conceive of that
would per persuade me to uh you know to
think that some kind of a change or
Amendment um and I and the other concern
I have is I think even the the the fact
that something other than this bill
dying happens um is itself sending a
signal I think to uh to uh the industry
and so I while I respect very much what
you say I I I just I have to say I
disagree so I think we I think we
probably need to vote on the OTP motion
uh at this point um Mr chair could I
also just ask you another question is
that clock
right yeah we got to get going to caucus
so so can we call the question on this
to get going have a a c a no so do we so
do we so I so we have six minutes left
it's 11:54 let's at least let's at least
get this bill out of the way I guess I
would propose representative H um yes I
now we'll have five and a half minutes
so I I'm a co-sponsor this bill there's
a major gun manufacturer that has
invested probably hundreds of millions
of dollars in my in the area where I
live and I have no problem with that and
I think they would stay regardless of
whether or not they they move move
they've had in addition the concern
about misuse of guns they did have a PR
product liability issue back about the
time when the original law that this
bill would overturn was passed and I
will say I've I'm satisfied that they've
been dealing with that product liability
issue as responsibly as they can so um
I'm going to vote Yes on the OTP but I I
I'm won't be shocked if that does fail
if that does not get a majority of the
committee so thanks representative Kenny
I moveed to call the question because we
like
so that's actually precisely my point I
feel I think representative Smith has
brought up a lot of good points that
warrant further discussion I've felt the
vibe that we do rush through some things
and and I don't know why I don't think
it's productive I I don't want to call
the question when people still want to
have a discussion on a bill and um I
understand we have a lot to get through
but I'm uncomfortable taking a vote on
this when we know members still want to
have a discussion and I concur on that
especially on a bill that's important
that we started the vote though and now
we have to get to caucus in 5 minutes we
have a motion on the table we have to
get to CAU that's the problem yeah I'm
gonna we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna vote it's just a point
of inquiry point of inquiry what pardon
is it possible I guess and Mr G
representative gon might be able to
answer the question is is it
procedurally possible someone withdraw
the motion are we already in the
process can I withdraw my
motion
I I think if it fails we can oh I think
if it fails then we can recess the
executive session until next week so
that's or when
eff
so um so per per representative gon my
understanding is the motion is still my
motion because there hasn't been OTP by
anyone else
right
no you can you can withdraw your motion
of OTP you can withd do that you can do
that I don't know if that helps the
cause my goal would my goal would be to
continue this I want here's what here's
what I saying is I want I my if you move
if you withdraw the OTP we will not have
a vote on OTP the next motion will be my
motion itl and we will have a vote on
that um so right so it's up to you
um I I guess I'll withdraw the motion
all right so then I would move it I
would move itl on I second Mr chair
second all right all right so anyone any
further seconded that motion Alexander
no no wait who seconded rep Alexander
second who who
seconded Eric's motion no you did I
thought I did yeah
um right
so and I would have to agree
to Mr chair I would like to take a
recess because of the fact that both
that all of us in this room have
caucuses that start at
noon and I am not quite ready to
withdraw my second of that
motion
all right let's well let's move
is
who's who's
this
this oh oh no no no all right no
no understand let's
know here's here's here's the thing I
think I think it's got to I will recess
this so you have more time to think what
I was say I I don't think that I don't
know if you
can I'm GNA call the I don't because we
need give me a second I'm call I don't
know if we
caness I think I think we I think we
need because no because no because what
I'm saying is this I'm more thany
I think I think on the floor it I think
on the floor we would kill the spill
because I think some of on the floor
some of some of your people would
would all right so
here's think
that what
you yeah no no no
I I I hear you I hear all
right
so all right so I think I'm unless she
tells me I can't do this I'm going to
recess right no exactly
exactly that is absolutely true but m my
obligation is to be
here I don't think I'm noted to to walk
out but people do
that right no I think that's what she's
that's what that's what representative K
problem is we're in the voting
mod no we're technically in the voting
mode what that's so what's
the
okay concern is just I don't
think no
that if I'm going to unless unless Smith
tells me I can't resar I'm going to
resar because I I I don't I don't you
know I don't like the idea of of sort of
forcing
people so so you know what listen I
I'm well if
we no so you know what if we've if uh
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
recess the the committee meeting if I if
if we're told that we can't recess I
assume that the only thing that would
mean is that we have to vote over again
on the motion of I of uh of the
amendment on the o on the your amend
your motion to amend and so we
presumably I don't think we're gonna
anybody's going to change their mind we
would have the same vote again so I sort
of feel like no harm no foul um so I'm
going to recess thank you all I'm sorry
I kept you over the line uh but um now
one just one other thing before we go
those of you who are going to write
reports could you get the reports to me
by the end of the day tomorrow all right
thank
you thank
you